6 41 is the time there's a name missing
from that we got to fix that well we'll
just i'll just we'll add you in yeah
just kind of fly i'll just smile
here we go yeah at 6 42 heather's with
us and so is monica hi monica i'm gonna
love watching this morning show hey
everybody
welcome like i said heather nice to meet
you in person john welcome back last
time i was here you had i think you were
still on vacation yeah yeah did you have
fun well i did come back but yes
hey i hope you guys have had a great
weekend and folks i hope you're having a
safe labor day i know it's the
unofficial end of summer don't worry
about it we'll still get the heat here
per sherry hey regular doctors visits
eye exams regular visits to our dentist
are really important but what about that
everyday nutrition and the vitamin
supplements are they just as important
well i spoke with a local compound
pharmacist his name is matt losarzo
about why compound pharmacies may be the
better solution
for you and me versus that
over-the-counter meds and vitamins check
it out
first of all tell us how long you've
been in this business and when did
compound pharmacy pharmacists come into
existence well i've been a pharmacist
since 1991
and in 1995 i started working at a small
compounding pharmacy in upstate new york
eventually i moved to vegas in 97
and then in 2006
me and a couple pharmacist friends we
opened up our own compounding pharmacy
here in vegas
very cool now matt you and i have had
this discussion years ago i reversed my
diabetes uh my pre-diabetes um by just
diet and exercise and then my doctor
said hey i need you to get some
supplements but i want you to go to a
compound pharmacy and i was like what
the heck is a compound pharmacy and
that's when i learned all about it and
the benefits of it so explain to our
viewers what a compound pharmacy is
so a compound pharmacy is
a specialized pharmacy that's able to
convert raw materials into final
products that patients can use whether
it be topical capsules liquid
suppository or we can take commercial
products that are made by factories and
turn them into products that different
types of patients can use like animals
and babies
wow okay all right so now what sets you
apart from the traditional slash
commercial pharmacy because if i'm
listening right now you know i'd be
thinking okay well my pharmacy can do
that too but what sets you guys apart
well theoretically theoretically any
pharmacy could do it but we choose to do
it it's a lot of man hours into it it's
a lot of expense at our time and our
money to do this we had to build a
facility that has four different rooms
in the back
to do sterile and non-sterile hazardous
and non-hazardous compounding
and we have the skill set in the books
and the research to be able to turn
these products into something that's
safe for people to use
okay so when it comes to compound
pharmacy um and and the medicines that
we get from you is it beneficial to our
everyday health and nutrition especially
when it comes to covet 19. you know
everybody's talking about zinc and
vitamin b and you know everybody's
trying to up the dosage and all that
kind of stuff what's your take
well zinc and vitamin d and quercetin
vitamin c they're all very important to
help build our immunity up and having a
better immunity is going to help you
fight off the covet virus if you catch
it yeah
and
you know you want to have a good quality
product so go somewhere where you trust
that the quality is there yeah and so
what are the benefits of your product
versus like that grocery store product i
know you use the word before compressed
and and the benefit of having more of
the actual substance that we need
explain that to our viewers so um
sometimes supplements in order to fit a
whole bunch of ingredients into a small
space they will take a bunch of powder
and compress it into a hard tablet
when you do that the body may or may not
be able to dissolve the whole product
before it gets through the system okay
there are other companies what will take
the same amount of product and put it in
two or three capsules
those capsules will break right apart
and the absorption to the body would
probably be a little bit better and
faster
yeah and so what are some of the other
benefits matt because i come to you i
get my
uh my protein shake i get my vitamin d i
get all kinds of things from you what
are some of the other benefits that you
think viewers should know about compound
pharmacists there's a lot of supplements
on the market that are good for adrenal
fatigue
if you went to a regular pharmacy i
don't think they'd have enough room on
their shelf to stock adrenal fatigue
medicines
they increase energy help you sleep at
night
make brain fog go away
that's one subset of
uh
medications over the counter that we
have probiotics we probably have 13
different probiotics in our pharmacy wow
fish oils three or four different fish
oils
okay and when it comes to price points
you know the first thing people think
about is okay
this sounds real good but it sounds real
expensive man
when it comes to pricing what are we
talking about in terms of differences i
i would say that products in a
compounding pharmacy are probably 20 to
30 percent more expensive than your your
local corner drugstore yeah well
if you look at some of the products like
fish oil
some of the products that you can get
for nine dollars on the shelf
when you look at the actual
potency of the active ingredients you
probably would need 11 of one capsule
instead of one or two of the 29 products
so wow cost may seem more but it may not
be as bad as you think yeah so you
really are quite literally getting more
bang for your buck because that one
capsule at your regular pharmacy you're
getting like maybe you know a little
smidget of what the actual product is or
the potency of it versus paying a little
bit more see that's what i like if i you
get what you pay for
right and and that's what i love and
that's why i wanted to bring you on the
show to talk about this with our viewers
compound pharmacy you know you have a
lot of choices and it's up to you right
now we're talking about things that are
happening here in the pandemic and
people are nervous and scared about
things but i wanted to put this one
option out there because i know a lot of
people have not heard about compound
pharmacy so you're here in las vegas
where are you located matt we're on the
southwest corner of eastern wigwam yeah
in
las vegas right across the street from
henderson
all right and folks uh you can check him
out and matt even told me that you know
he's not even trying to push his own
business he said there are four about
four compounding pharmacies across the
las vegas valley but he just wants
people to know that uh during the
pandemic you gotta up your game with
your health and so hopefully that
information will help a lot of you out
and i really appreciate that matt so
thank you so much folks don't forget to
catch the mlj show facebook live at 7
p.m tonight yeah so sherry you know i i
told you i i fell off the wagon during
the pandemic and my doctor diagnosed me
with diabetes again oh this is my second
time around with type 2 and so i had to
buckle down and i'm on right now about
16 supplements just to get back on track
wow and then i got to go back to my
doctor and then she's going to
re-evaluate she said that number's going
to come down but the compound pharmacy
and all the all of these supplements
that i've been getting they have really
changed my life yeah and what i love
about matt because i know matt as well
he comes out from behind the counter
he'll walk through the store with you
and really tell you what you need what
you may not need what works well
together doesn't and some of these
compounding pharmacies they do custom
hormones yes they do a lot of good
things yeah and for women in particular
i think it's very important that they
know yeah good stuff
thank you great interview